a warm day here in the Kansas City area
Rob Riggle joining me here David
Koechner
literally you snooze you lose so Rob
gets to sit directly next to the set
dressing that we have here in the form
of the 2015 Kansas City Road I'm gonna
touch it but backhand your backhanding
weight it's nice gentle you know oils no
I mean this is a like the Lombardi
Trophy a piece of Tiffany artless made
by Tiffany and company and Coe oh yeah
and so JIT it is legit and you're not
allowed to touch it unless you you have
gloves so I'm glad you back Kent yes I
this is a true story years ago when I
was on the NFL Network live at the Super
Bowl between the Patriots and the Eagles
the first one not the one that we go
we had the Lombardi Trophy on the set as
set-dressing there to remember the sale
to and we had Terry Bradshaw on how he
longed on the show and I was talking to
them alive and I asked Terry you know
pointing to the trophy what's it like to
pick up that trophy and he moves to go
and pick it up and a member of the
Lombardi Trophy security detail in her
yellow security slicker jumped on the
set in front of him like she was
stopping a bullet on the way there's
somebody very important and not even
Terry Bradshaw who has rightfully held
it was allowed to touch it without
gloves until they gave him gloves so he
could touch it yes okay but he was about
to commit a sin a very large yes yes
interesting thing is Rob's wife's name
is Tiffany yeah and same thing same rule
unable to can you confirm wrong I can't
confirm or deny but they do have
children so the other time he has to
wear gloves I'm sorry what I'm well
thank you saw you last week in our
lawsuit I know this is great this is
like weeks in a row now I just saw that
you removed from Rob's KC big slick
t-shirt occur we were at the hot
yeah sticker what was that like for you
guys just coming back from children
fantastic that's the whole reason we're
here you know this weekend is to raise
money for Children's Mercy Hospital in
Kansas City they they do the most
amazing work you've ever seen the staff
the families the nurses the doctors the
patients everybody is is truly amazing
over there and so we spent this morning
with them talking with them visiting
with them and it's always inspiring it's
always inspiring I would say it's nice
because this is the ninth year of big
slick 9s we always go back so we see a
lot of familiar faces on the staff and
it feels like family if it genuinely
feels like we're part of something
certainly much larger than ourselves and
the fact that we can be of service and
be benefactors to it this great amazing
Hospital is really rewarding and the
thing that I always been struck by it is
a family affair for you guys too I mean
Jason Sudeikis his mom does the travel
Paul Rudd's mom does some of the PR
right my sister and my brother-in-law do
all the operations yeah my sister does
the operation it's amazing they work
tirelessly snow streets is through
liaisons with the hospital and produces
a lot of stuff there so yeah it's it's
it's all of our families are tied into
this and they all work very hard but
before we raise money tomorrow night
yeah
comes the competition this evening how
does this all happen are you guys
captains of this thing I mean what a
well how does this how does this work
tonight
some of that is predetermined we have
blue and white jerseys blue you know
home and away jerseys and and we we get
are all of our celebrity guest names in
advance what numbers they want and then
we like I asked for a Lacock Jersey well
done Pete Lacock the son of Peter
Marshall yes who was the host of
Hollywood Squares which amazing you know
what I'm saying amaze I'm going deep yes
right now I'm almost I mean we're almost
one step away from Paul Lynde which
means we're two steps removed from Kevin
Bacon somehow I played golf one time
with Peter Marshall here in Kansas City
when I was like 13 years old and and I
had him a test the scorecard which I
didn't even keep accurately but I just
wanted
his autograph but I didn't want to ask
so that's how I got his not so daddy
circle anyway where did INEX get a
square wait he did he put he put arrows
in question marks by a lot of high
scores and then sign it okay so I'm do I
do you know which team I don't know
which team you're on we that's the fun
reveal as we we come down and you see
what Jersey you have and you're like oh
my god it's so it's so it's sort of like
the the baby reveal I will have either a
blue or blue or white or a why okay is
there a scouting report I don't think so
yes on this one yes well we know your
this is his third big sling this is your
third big slick yes oh thank you by the
way thank you come on and your whole
team yep oh wait Chris guys thank you so
much it's last night yes karaoke master
I don't know about mass master he was
doing heavy metal he was doing we did
not we crew we did Bon Jovi we were
hitting all the spam well I think we
could do rings you know in the same way
that the artificial intelligence expert
might have caught the general manager of
the Philadelphia 76ers with his hand in
the Twitter cookie Jeff I think we can
cross-reference exactly when the Oakland
Athletics complain how loud we were this
was the first with his Born to Run or
what do we were a hungry heart I think
well it hit a note that has never been
hit before and I think that resonated
throughout the entire hotel I down your
money and play your parts guys okay from
what happened and I was kind of privy to
it yes we're having a karaoke Jam we're
having a party this is par for the
course for the big slick it is that and
Chris is lighting up the stage with his
his his honey on his voice just magic
yes and the security comes up and says
hey guys you got to tone it down we're
getting complaints come place from oh
yeah the Oakland Athletics which
everybody just simultaneously looked at
each other turn it up what the worst
thing you could have told us that's just
one that's next level from just merely
pulling the fire alarm yes you know what
I mean absolutely descend Brockman out
there are the hungry hearts so we we
open tracks the security guy out
and turned it up and took it to another
level that was a stupidest thing you
could have told do I want though do I
want the Athletics to sleep oh give them
nightmares yeah so tonight's final score
we already know you go to the wire that
little edge little after the game after
the game they'll go up to Bob Melvin
like what like what was the difference
tonight well it's right around 1:00 in
the morning I heard something like is
sound like a muffled screams of Bruce
Springsteen on the way it's gonna sound
like someone was choking Bruce
Springsteen by the way great would be a
great sort of fantasy team name or
something all right let's take a break
when we come back I want to get deeper
into the Gene Lamont of oh yeah hey
we've discussed it I think separately in
your big in your your appearance is back
in our Los Angeles yes but that is a big
slick tradition is haranguing Gene
Lamont yeah Tom way shape or form it
started as a mild heckle and is turned
into a glorious celebration
Rob Riggle and Dave Koechner here live
on the Rich Eisen show from the home of
the Royals on our simulcast emanating
from the big slick fake slick kc.org the
doughnut
[Music]
all right couple minutes for our TV only
audience so last night you come up to me
rob and you're like hey I played a
Michigan guy yeah
what were you doing I said this is my
typical Michigan guy that's what I
figure he looks like tell me if I'm
wrong hold on let me hold it up I would
say you're wrong because that's I don't
know what just yeah no I think I got
eyes are the mullet the mustache so what
I look at you reclining in your
director's chair on the set there I mean
what yeah why it was well is this your
interpretation of what a Michigan fan a
Michigan man man of leisure is with the
title of the the new it's a major
blockbuster feature where are we going
to see this see to some of your finer
theaters see coffee I think I like I
said I haven't been to the big house
which is something I desperately want to
do yes but I this was my best guess at
what I think a Michigan fan looks like
well why don't you reach out to me and I
could have helped work shall I know now
I know yeah now I know yeah III would
have definitely said no mullet no
pornstache
you know the whistle I like the Harbaugh
you know top how about the the visor was
that on point visor is you know that it
helped the mullet it really accentuated
the mullet that's a choice don't act
like you don't know I like the khakis or
a good move thank you thank you
I thought is a fair representation thank
you thank tell you I live as you called
over a number of years and the folks
that would come over from the big MIT
always with a corduroy Michigan hat you
just spot them at the bars like stay
away from those fellas what was harmed
in the making of those boots a pair of
okuu fish is a fish it's a fish hide
what it's and it stays fresh fish it
doesn't smell peanut okuu it's a
ten-foot Amazonian fish
wow that's way too there we go did you
get that on the set of anchorman no I
bought these couple weeks ago at the
country general store they're in uh in
Los Angeles I thought you're gonna say
you want it prizefighting in Thailand I
should be a Muay Thai boxer and use
these
if you were to show up in the ring in
the short with your hands wrap I would
put a lot of money on you this afternoon
I should come out shorts these boots
because normally rich wear I do for the
big slick softball game is is akin to
what you do I just run my mouth I'm like
the announcer at Aston yeah Rob Riggle
and uh and David Koechner here a couple
more minutes left with the two of the
five hosts of the big select Paul Rudd
and Eric Stonestreet will be here an
hour
number three stone streets bringing with
him Mitchell Schwartz of the Kansas City
Chiefs pressure off the OTA practice
field and Rudd's bringing Bret
Saberhagen with him so that I'll be
later on I brought Dave Koechner with me
you did man well actually Dave brought
you with him well we so agree to
disagree but got it Gene Lamont is a
longtime baseball man he was a
third-base coach for many years with the
Detroit Tigers I'll never forget my
first big slick when I came here and it
was Royals versus Tigers and the Tigers
were it back top of the first Gene
Lamont strolls out to the third-base
coaching box I'm standing in the dugout
with the rest of you guys and then you
start getting on this gentleman for you
didn't do a thing he just strolled out
to his position and then you guys start
screaming it
sweet sweet sweet Jean Lamont made the
sorry mistake of standing in front of us
that's a huge mistake
first of all especially you're going to
be in a Detroit Tigers uniform at the K
mm-hmm so we were doing an interview
with a local news station down in the
dugout sweet Will Farrell myself Paul
and Jason and Gene Lamont comes out to
coach third base just doing his job but
the name Lamont is so fun to scream and
I didn't realize it until Will Ferrell
started screaming hey Lamont
see that just rolls and he go this is
bush league Lamont and he just got on
him and so when he started we all
started and then it just became a never
ending ever for the entire inning we
would just scream out of nothing
terrible because we're not rude and
we're not
hackie but it was just this is
bush-league Lamott what are you doin
Lamont take that stuff back to Detroit
Lamont doesn't play here Lamont you know
it's simple stuff but Lamont was on the
end of everything so we lay into him for
about seven innings oh and I think like
I'm not sure but I think Johnny Damon
might have been playing for the Tigers
at that point and he would run by the
dugout sweet and and he would be like
are you guys yelling Omaha yes because
the only reason he's on third Bay he was
right in front of us he was like 20 feet
away from us so we just rode him hard
and I in it and he was right year after
year after year
well then on follow-on big slicks same
thing it was gentleman on 3rd coaching
third and we've just ride him
relentlessly finally I think of year two
of writing of somebody who'd whispered
in his ear by the way there's there's
Will Ferrell and these guys are in there
and they're giving you a hard time and
so he finally because we were all we
wanted was him to acknowledge us he's I
don't know it was like seventh inning of
the second he turned around when I just
looked at us and gave him it like a head
nod and It was as if we won the World
Series ah we started screaming and
jumping up and down and we were waving
our hat in the air and then we were so
enamored with gene but we go out and
sing the seventh-inning stretch take me
out to the ballgame
yeah right yeah and we ended now you
know we end the song with gene Lamont's
that's not gonna happen tonight that's
going to happen his tradition but now
he's part of the Royals front office
this is the beautiful thing about coming
full circle now D now Gene Lamont
he's a Royals Arroyo he's on our side so
we love him even more but when he used
to come out we used to sing like the the
Death Star March like the Darth Vader we
go
Gene Lamont Gene Lamont Oh gene Lamont
Gene Lamont Gene Lamont anything we
could nothing he gave us nothing but now
he's a royal so we embrace him with open
arms yeah now it's all about love before
it was harassment yeah it was derision
and no longer that oh it's just love is
he gonna be included tonight in some way
shape or oh my eye I beg I beg that he
come and join us I will do anything but
I met he's a working man he's a
professional yes he and he he takes his
craft series
so he may be focused on the game but if
we can lure him out for the
seventh-inning stretch or any part of
the game yeah we will be honored to have
him it's a circle of lamont if you think
about it it's the full it's still about
circle it's he's gone he's got to
deliver the sword the ceremonial first
pitch of the softball I'm just I'm just
spitballing I don't know what his
schedules like man of lamont means you
haven't said anything wrong yet my
friend you haven't said anything wrong
thanks for having us here by the way
thank you thank you are you kidding me
guys much they get the word out thanks
for coming to Kansas City bringing your
team it's an honor
thanks Lee kc.org the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience